how would you just really clearly
articulate the difference between a
recruiter that does one two three deals
with a client every quarter to what
you're talking about solutions outcomes
what would you say is the the main
difference do you think the main
difference is like yeah you're actually
a partner like you're working with a
client you know where they're going as a
business you're integrated into what
they want yeah looking at their goals
and objectives so we've got a project
coming up and you're building a new
application for your business where
someone can sign in and apply for a job
on your website so you need to build a
whole new system for that so having
those conversations rather than all
right mate so you want a front-end
developer okay okay so what is this
actually gonna do what is the impact on
the business if it doesn't happen and
how can we help you get there the first
step is to just go and have that
conversation what is going on with your
business obviously you've got to find
out where these projects are going i've
got to go out and get the information
then go and speak to people i've seen
that you've recently received funding
and you're going to be building this
team above let me talk to you about how
we can help you do that so it's
literally about understanding
that you're not just there to give them
a person yeah it's there to solve the
problem that they've got and having that
conversation with clients being willing
to have those conversations yeah the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker